How is semantic networks connected with human cognition?
Well we can make at least two connections immediately. First,
semantic networks are kind of knowledge representation. We saw hive knowledge is
presented as a semantic network. If the results of [UNKNOWN] representation,
then you can use the knowledge presentation to address the problem.
We can now say similarly for human mind that human mind represents problems.
It represents knowledge. Then it uses that knowledge to address the problem.
So, representation then becomes the key. Second, and most specifically,
semantic networks are related to spreading activation networks,
which is a very popular theory of human memory. Let me give you an example.
Supposing I told you a story consisting of just two sentences. John wanted to
become rich. He got a gun. And notice that I did not tell you the entire story,
but I'm sure you all made up a story based on what I told you.
John wanted to become rich. He decided to rob a bank.
He got a gun in order to rob the bank. But how did you end this story?
How did it draw the inferences about robbing a bank which I did not tell you
anything about? Imagine if you have a semantic network that consisted of
a large number of nodes. So when I gave you the first sentence, John wanted to
become rich, the nodes corresponding to John and wanted and become and
rich, got activated, and the activation started spreading from those nodes.
And when I said John, he got a gun, then the gun node also got activated and
that activation also started spreading. As this activation spread,
it merged. And a path they could walk on. And all the nodes on that
pathway now become part of the story, and if you happen to have nodes like,
rob a bank along the pathway, now you have understanding of story.